hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the evil within I
got some food in my belly so now I can
actually concentrate and use my brain to
100% capacity also this looks very
familiar from the original game I mean I
do recall travelling it across a
decrepit falling apart city that for
some odd reason goes into the pits of
Hell I mean I don't know why I don't
know what have you done why don't you
take some responsibility for your
actions maybe you did nothing to do with
this I have no idea because your whole
role in this seems very strange I don't
know why mobis would pick you up to
train you for such an important mission
unless you had some other things about
you that made you exceptionally valuable
okay I'm assuming and I can drop down
there but it seems like there's a path
over here that might be secondary to
where I need to go it might have a
secret because I do not want to miss out
on any secrets this is this is exactly
what I was doing wait a minute we're
Sebastian
what was that who's writhing in pain
over there and why also do I need to go
this way man this feels like I missed
something I'm gonna double back just to
make sure that there wasn't like another
path that I could have gone down because
it looks like I could jump on that but I
guess there's no point to jumping on
that because there's no other place to
go after that all right I guess this is
the only way then I know I did also just
get a page very recently so it might be
that not as important hi Wow isn't this
a lovely party did I crash something
here oh hello I'm gonna hide now
do that now I'm on fire he Oh God now
those books brought hurt a lot so what
am I supposed to do about this you seem
to be having fun over there but what
about me having fun well
you little bit of poop oh okay Oh
looking good oh really okay this is
where the gun comes in I guess I really
hope they don't give me a lot more than
this but this does seem like a more
actually part and usually in the finale
games you know it's good
thank you he's on fire oh no that got
the attention of those a-holes what am I
gonna do probably this flap flap okay
good for me so finally I have a gun
oh they're giving me or more ammo this
must be running up to the conclusion of
this because this was getting close to
the conclusion because as soon as we got
back to beacon hospital that's when
things started to make sense now I don't
think I'm gonna go on the crazy trip of
trying to defeat giant brain with a
Rubik in it oh no I created a pathway
what kind of doofus am I well they'll
never find me if they don't know where I
is oh yeah I forgot
oh whoops sorry sorry sorry sorry damn
it oh okay I'm dead now I am not used to
shooting on a controller I am great with
a mouse and keyboard but controller I
don't know it feels like really wanted
to kill that guy behind him I didn't
think he was a threat I thought he was
coming on to me so you know he seemed
you mean give me give me a hot hot
second dinner that's a Miss well missed
again okay fourth myth fifth six seven
dad did barely anything okay it's three
body walk
why am I so bad oh man just come on come
on Wow Wow I'm so bad come on oh why oh
why am I so bad God if I was doing this
on a mouse I can't do it automatically I
have a mouse and keyboard right in front
of me and it changes immediately that's
actually really cool all right let's try
this again this time where'd you put no
keep your gun out no let me reload no
stop there you present your face to be
exploded this is going much better I
can't believe I didn't do this sooner
well look at me go I'm so great at the
barrel that didn't save me any bullets
at all hello a friend how you doing oh
you dodge all you dodge again or I'm
terrible at shooting either one either
way I don't know which is more true
neither I miss any yeah there were some
more bullets over here so now that
that's out of the way hopefully we can
be done with the shooting sequence and I
can move on with my life
now that I've properly I mean I could
play the rest of the game with a mouse
and keyboard but there was something
just a little more like elegant about
playing with a controller I mean I'm
pretty sure did I play with a controller
in the beginning like in the original
game I did
for some reason I just automatically
hooked up my controller for this one so
I must assume that there was some reason
for me to do that right don't know yeah
well whatever let's keep going now that
can bring skill a little bit into
equation what's all this that ah just
wanted to do that for show
okay let me I'm gonna switch back now
who is helping me paranoia
really paranoia paranoia route 16 route
13 interstate 16
who are you oh no you don't so now I can
very much what why am I not whoa where
am I
whoa get back please back please no you
and you're not so sexy legs
in testan road is that paranoia street
did you vixen you well I hope he gets
the message I'm a badass blam oh that's
almost anticlimactic
I finished her off so quickly I thought
I was gonna be running around for a
while
that's the thing when it's a change of
plate a change of pace like that like I
was kind of hoping there would be a way
to finish this off with a more scary
route but like even amnesia the Dark
Descent it went a little like out of
this world that I'm quoting the actual
game out of this world and not so much
staying within the theme that carried in
the original way it was very much poorer
yes I'm here who's calling me sounds
good okay hey it's me too
is that all five nights at freddy gets
me or is that just as generally it's
actually you oh yes this is what I was
looking for save it for later they're
probably more of them around
whoa that's weird
vampirey all right I don't know what you
did
did you shoot Rubick okay that's rather
tender
what sort of backstory do you have ah
that's right that was the last thing
that she said cuz it seemed rather mean
when she just did that are you Leslie
how's it going
as I recall they're a bunch of horrible
things in the water here hey hope I
don't need to do the Mitch man it really
sucks so that that was the end of the
flashlight head sexy leg lady slag lady
slag lady with hasty with that gun
hey you said that before what is it you
plan on doing
grabby hands again Oh God okay here we
go
whoa probably while that didn't go very
well they're not excuses
they're turning
no not necessarily whoo hey what the
hell is that
that's what I said
wasn't there a sequence where Jojo and
Kidman were all on a bus oh there's the
bus I was just wondering about that
keeping this thing gonna run hello hi
there hey what are you doing I don't ask
Oh am i gonna be driving the boss
that's so crazy
drive this is same cutscene hello
classroom yeah exactly that's what I was
thinking before oh that's so cool
ah but I am really sad that slag lady I
guess is what I'm calling her now hey
we're sexy leg lady slag lady yeah sure
let's go with that but I was kind of
disappointed that that was the end of it
like it went by so quickly like it
really sucks that as soon as I got a gun
I was able to dispatch her like that so
it's unfortunate the way that is but
that's how empowering that ones are when
you get them in horror games this is
like those sounds are the found of
happiness key so what do about an you
discern between evil and good
hello okay oh yeah that's right bus
crash okay I got it now so so uh so what
about all this oh no my god yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
damn it watch your language young lady
yes but now it sucks even more because
slag lady is gone and now who's gonna
replace leg lady a ghost is born a ghost
in the machine a ghost in the shell
which actually really like you know
often what people ask me what my
favorite anime is you know I haven't
watched anyway I say full metal
alchemist but I often forget that not be
kept here
who the hell are you what the hell is
that
that's an interesting idea to have
immediately at that point but I don't
see how do I take that fire hey Blair
hey this is a good idea I just got this
myself sure why not
okay all right oh yeah he doesn't like
fire how did she know that because he
was burned as a kid remember that's why
he was so angry because those villagers
like earned him up okay
wait no I got a backtrack I got to make
sure because in here definitely in here
they're gonna hide a scrap of paper
they're definitely gonna hide one I know
it I know it I know I know I mean maybe
not in here specifically but I want to
just double-check everything I was kind
of going quickly through it I got
excited because they took away my gun
poor slag lady okay it doesn't look like
there's anything over there that's a
nice shower great view from that shower
over there okay I just had to
double-check because if I would didn't
double-check and I pop up and I find it
page six I'm going to be very very upset
at myself and then the internet is gonna
be mad at me I know that emotionally
like lies I
I really do wonder why bullets actually
affect ruvik or if they do at all I mean
obviously do they do when Sebastian was
fighting the huge weird battle bullets
and explosives hello at least they're
alright please just stay out of my way
you're right there Kidman you doing okay
you doing alright alright alright
whatever alright cool alright bye now
that was weird alright didn't do another
vent oh man did I miss oh I didn't look
around there did I well let me go back
oh no if I miss something oh no no did I
miss something
oh I really hope I didn't miss it I look
I look pretty thoroughly I think I'm
okay but I I will not forgive myself if
I miss that and if you guys already know
if I missed it I've failed you all
I filled everybody
are you doing what is with you make a
decision commit those are fun sounds the
fire incident and subsequent abuse from
his parents
it's a miracle Ruben can function at all
heat his work comes from a place that
isn't motivated by fear or money or
social standing is mutters Amara pure I
would say that he is obsessed with the
chance to relive and remould reality so
he can be with her again his scarring is
heavy both physically and emotionally
but he longs for his lost sister his
love for her borders almost on an
incestuous level but as long as it
provides motivation so be it all right
well why not throw incest in there he
was already messed up enough as it is
I'm I'm really trying to pay as close
attention as possible to everything that
I got here I feel like I missed
something
hey Leslie lot light wisely don't know -
okay you ran away all right good good
good good good good good
is there something bad behind that door
okay bye
I need another scrap of paper
I need another scrap I don't know if
there were six in total because in the
last DLC I didn't get all of them so I
don't even know if the well that's
bizarre
Wow I didn't know that it was time to
shower with but bugs blood bugs is this
the scene from The Shining
this is where it all went down mmm I
wonder if I'm supposed to go in the Hat
door something tells me something fun's
behind here hello Leslie come on
I knows what I needs to do I need to
find some fire ooh okay did not know
there are other people here yeah
probably but I mean you know why would
you want to well there's so many reasons
why you want this goes absolutely
nowhere there was no point for me to
come over here all right you know what
whoa hey how's it going there friend no
no no no no no no no what are you doing
what you can't see me when when I was
when I was playing before obviously it
was without a gun and it was fine cuz
that was the rhythm and that was the
night but now I don't have a weapon
again but the element of fear has been
removed so instead of making it a
necessity out of survival it's a
necessity out of making it a challenge
to fight these guys and that's not
necessarily a bad thing I'm not being
critical here I'm just saying why it's
jarring for me it's jarring to suddenly
transition into a way where hey we're
not supposed to play the way we were
playing before we're we're doing what
we're doing but the setting is different
so yeah yeah there you go and then and
then when it cycles back and forth
that's what sorry it's not bad not bad
in any way I'm not saying that it's bad
or only totally my fault I should have
been better I shouldn't have gotten
noticed in the first place
totally admitting that one under
Versailles it's it's not this games
doing it's it's me I'm
I was the dumb okay apparently the
sticks forever and I don't know why it
takes forever cuz usually fire moves a
lot faster Bernie Bernie Bernie Bernie
Bernie Bernie done be free Leslie be
free like a bird run away again make me
chase after you Thanks yeah of course it
works maybe I don't know he seems to
have a weakness for fire the big baby
okay they're like another axe around
here that I could have gotten to take
care of the other guy anything over here
I feel like I'm missing a page piece all
right okay I'm just operating on
assumption that I did everything right
BAM Leslie get back here I've got
assassin for you wait a minute oh never
mind I thought I saw something
never mind it's just everything's shiny
over here and I Association II with
things that I can actually pick up there
hey it just so happens that's a whole
lot of me come on hurry faster do it
more okay what's going on in here oh is
this where I'm supposed to be or is this
a bonus I never know like is this
progressing or is this side tracking oh
no its side tracking there we go okay so
there's got to be I see the colors on
the dials so there's got to be a
combination somewhere oh there we go 24
that one didn't have a number over there
okay yellow 2400 red ten yellow 24 red
10 ah blue six
okay got it okay please please be paid
six oh it's five oh okay good that's
even better I would have forgotten if I
had been six I would have been
celebrating like yeah I haven't missed
one and then you all have been faced
bombing but I did it okay good Oh
oh that's a big load
all right Leslie come back come back to
me follow the sound of my voice that's
an interesting thing
it's either knives or spotlights
depending on what you see kitty kitty
kitty kitty kitty kitty Danny
Yui Hey slag lady ain't here no more to
bother you okay let me live no mother
humper bumper bumper okay I meant to
listen to the thing on the table first
but apparently I wanted to pet this
kitty told we're gonna do that fine
get off I need to listen to this before
I end the esses oat episode s abode
whatever long whoa what is the
transition take so long it's a vestige
mere husk of what was bound to be such a
home of promise hmm
Mobius reaped nearly everything of value
when we took on the research ourselves
but years
Ruben's notes indicate he was involved
in something else there were plans for
another stem prototype data about using
receptors to transmit the brain function
wirelessly to unaware users it's
borderline parapsychology but these
schematics and the scientific backer
provided seems sound what was he
planning to do was such a thing there's
only one way to find out for certain but
I must continue these experiments in
private away from their prying eyes no
yes they take this from me as well yeah
so the best thing to do would record all
of your private thoughts everything that
could possibly be incriminating about
your life or your experience and how
devious they are and how devious anyone
else involved with what you're doing are
recorded also that no one can find it in
a dream
okay or maybe they're not recorded maybe
these are actually his thoughts like and
they're just in the stream world because
it's that way either way that's a
mystery for another day thank you
everybody so much for watching how long
has that baby been there click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and I really hope you're enjoying
this because I'm thoroughly enjoying it
even the combat section I can I can
totally forgive and it's it's okay
because it made sense in that time
because in the original game that's when
she was shooting shoot oh it makes sense
it had to happen
that makes sense I get it now okay it
had to happen ah that's great okay thank
you again everybody and as always I will
see you in the next video